another mystery of Star Wars a rise of
Skywalker has been solved to be another
one's coming out near the film's end
right after the triumph of Rey /
granddad Emperor Palpatine she and kylo
Ren appeared to exchange words before
the latter vanishes into the force but
no dialogue between the two is audible
as it turns out they did have some
parting words after all and the movie
Stovall ization is apparently letting us
in on what they had to say to each other
you'll recall that Rey egged on by the
voices of Jedi pass in her head was able
to seal Palpatine's destruction by
deflecting his own hateful nasty forced
lightning back at him apparently
mortally wounding himself in the process
kylo however having decided to go ahead
and turn back to the light side and
become Ben solo again transferred his
life force to her at the last minute
they had those mysterious words shared a
chaste kiss and then he was gone
curious according to the novelization
their exchange wasn't exactly the most
creative thing in the world if you
happen to take a guess as to what they
might have said the chances are fairly
good that you were right I couldn't
really guess the relevant passage in the
book reads a voice came to her through
the force clear and strong I will always
be with you Ben said she smiled let the
truth of it wash over her no one's ever
really gone she whispered no one's ever
really gone there you have it folks that
clears that right up the revelation is a
fairly minor one among the other story
related things that have become known in
the months following rights of
Skywalker's release as it's becoming
increasingly clear a whole lot of
seemingly important plot material for
episode 9 just straight-up wasn't in the
movie to understand what happened Disney
apparently would rather you find out in
a book sold separately of course sacred
Jack the rise of Skywalker has been
accompanied by a pretty substantial
amount of game-changing supplemental
material the starters there's a movie's
visual dictionary released on the same
day the film came out the ginormous tome
revealed such plot points as a fact that
as many suspected ex stormtrooper Jana
is lando calrissian long-lost daughter
the character your prank Jana she's
Lando Calrissian daughter that book also
revealed that the planet kylo visits on
the film's opening is indeed the same
one of Mustapha where anakin skywalker
lost his famous game of
Flores lover with obi-wan Kenobi and
that the candy apple Seth troopers who
show up out of nowhere to serve on his
Star Destroyers are actually the
children of Palpatine's worshippers on
exa Gul oh and for some reason it also
suggests that the vaunted Knights of the
Old Republic RPG is apparently canon
again why not you get a high from what
you once were more lost plot points on
the movie will likely be laid out by the
five issue rights of Skywalker comic
series to be published by Marvel Comics
starting in May 2020 and you might
recall that even more details about the
movie literally had to be explained by
the movie's crew in various interviews
for example the film's editor mary and
brandon dive out in a conversation with
huffington post's why rey was unable to
simply kill Emperor Palpatine explaining
that she basically can't strike him down
in anger
apparently it's only by reflecting his
own hate back at him or in this case
lighting bolts that she's able to beat
him at his nefarious schemes on another
occasion director JJ Abrams himself
revealed what it was that Finn kept
trying to tell ray for the entire movie
turns out that he wants to tell her that
he's force sensitive and not like you
might imagine that he secretly loves her
boyfriend boyfriend none of your
business that's why depending on whom
you ask this will makes rise of
Skywalker either a automatically rich
narrative lead dense work containing too
much story to fit into its runtime or be
an incomplete film which asks its fans
to shell out extra cash to fill in its
plot holes I think you're alright if you
happen to enjoy the rise of Skywalker
just finances more power to you but
either way we hope the next movie can
manage to fit a whole story in before
the credits roll and that leaves a good
stuff for the books the rights of
Skywalker warhead to digital platforms
of March 17th and DVD blu-ray on March
31st check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
buy your favorite movies and TV shows
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you